while the rivers and ponds are melting  the ground remains frozen and under the  leaf litter someone is pulling off a  miracle  this wood frog is frozen solid even his  eyes are iced over there's no pulse no  breath  slowly the warmth of spring begins to  thaw from the inside out his heart  starts beating  his brain lights up  and he begins to move  it turns out that the frog's liver  pumped a syrupy natural antifreeze into  his cells in the fall it kept his organs  from freezing only the water between  cells froze  after eight months frozen he's  completely undamaged and leaping  straight for the nearest pond now  alaska's least welcomed yearly arrival  slowly bursts from its watery home the  mosquito and it immediately wants blood  not even cold blooded frogs are immune  the number of mosquitoes here far  outstrips that in any jungle on earth  [Music]  [Music]